[Música]
El que ríe de último ríe mejor este
viejo refrán se ajusta perfectamente a
lo que ha vivido Richi zunak quien fue
elegido como nuevo líder de los
conservadores y por lo tanto nuevo
Primer Ministro del Reino Unido hace
solamente tres meses fue sunac quien
disputó la nominación contra Alice Trust
quien resultó ser elegida y solamente 45
días después tuvo que abandonar el cargo
de primera ministra ahora es
precisamente sunak el nuevo residente en
el número 10 de downing Street Quién es
este joven político hijo de inmigrantes
indios que llamó la atención de los
británicos durante el confinamiento
debido a las decisiones que tomó a nivel
económico para hacer frente a la
pandemia de Kobe 19 veamos algunos datos
que hemos preparado para ustedes Richi
es una que nació en la ciudad de
Southampton es graduado De filosofía
política y también economía de la
Universidad de Oxford y saltó digamos lo
de esa manera a la escena política al
ser ministro de hacienda del Primer
Ministro Boris Johnson También estuvo
envuelto en el escándalo del partygate
por esta razón tuvo que pagar una multa
también durante su gestión se enfocó en
brindar asistencia a quienes recibieron
los efectos más drásticos a nivel
económico dejados por la pandemia del
Coby 19 cerca de 400.000 millones de
dólares en diferentes fondos públicos
fueron dados durante la gestión de sunac
allí en el Reino Unido luego fue
criticado precisamente por el aumento de
los impuestos una vez la economía empezó
a regresar a su estado normal también
fue fuertemente señalado por los
conservadores por su alta posición
económica pertenece a una acaudalada
familia gracias a su matrimonio hay
quienes dicen que pertenecer justamente
a la clase alta británica lo aleja de la
realidad que enfrentan los ciudadanos de
a pie qué tanta conexión entonces tiene
sunak con el británico o normal con el
británico de a pie con la realidad que
viven en sus hogares de cara al invierno
un invierno donde hay serias
preocupaciones a nivel energético no
solamente en el Reino Unido sino también
en el resto de Europa cuál debe ser
Entonces el primer frente que debe
atacar el nuevo Primer Ministro qué
rumbo debe tomar el Reino Unido Y cómo
puede precisamente el Reino Unido
recuperar esa posición de Liderazgo a
nivel europeo y a nivel mundial que
prometía el brexit brexit que justamente
apoyó Sonic en su momento para conversar
sobre este tema hemos invitado a Dámaso
Morales Ramírez él es coordinador del
centro de estudios europeos de la
facultad de ciencias políticas de la
Universidad Nacional Autónoma de México
y también está con nosotros Óscar
Martínez él es profesor de la
universidad
hayi en la ciudad de Madrid y en
nuestros también les recuerdo a nuestros
televidentes que ustedes también hacen
parte de este debate de esta
conversación pueden dejar todos los
comentarios preguntas que ustedes deseen
sobre este tema a través de las redes
sociales estamos en Twitter en Facebook
en instagram ustedes ya lo saben no se
encuentran como el debate guión bajo
f24@santilogo que es en mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 y no olviden también que
todos los contenidos de este programa
están disponibles en podcast en
diferentes plataformas estamos en Apple
podcast en Spotify deezer y TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Dámaso bienvenida y también la primera
pregunta a Punto de partida para conocer
las posiciones de nuestros invitados
sobre este tema y damas o Gracias por
estar con nosotros en el programa
esperada la elección de sunat qué
opinión tiene usted sobre este nuevo
Primer Ministro que tendrá que llevar
las riendas del Reino Unido un Reino
Unido que tiene muchos frentes de
batalla abiertos que ya vamos a analizar
aquí en el programa
este Muchas gracias gusto en saludarte
Santiago Sin lugar a dudas es un reto
enorme para sunar en virtud de que
sabemos que ella había competido y no
había quedado Se le señala como ser el
ministro que de alguna manera provocó la
caída del propio Boris Johnson es cierto
el participó en Estas fiestas Pero él
también después se desprendió un poco de
la política de Boris Johnson y ahora
aparece como este nuevo Primer Ministro
con una agenda muy complicada ya lo
habías mencionado este en términos muy
generales lo que es la economía y lo que
es la crisis política porque si no para
dudas todo esto ha significado una
crisis política y más para el partido
conservador que él ahora estaría
liderando Entonces es una que también
tiene otro reto que es el hacerse
conocer precisamente ante la población
británica porque fuera de estos últimos
procesos pues realmente no se conocía
mucho azul y ahora él tiene que hacerse
un nombre lo mismo ya como Primer
Ministro ante todo el pueblo británico
lo que es el reino africano
la opinión de Dámaso Morales en México
Vamos ahora a preguntarle a Óscar
Martínez por este Punto de partida la
misma pregunta si era una esperada
elección la de Richi zonas allá en el
Reino Unido Y qué opinión tiene usted
sobre esta elección
muy bien muy muy muy buenas noches desde
Madrid a damas hoy a Santiago un placer
estar con vosotros vamos a ver yo creo
que precisamente hoy lunes las cosas se
han precipitado de una manera que quizá
durante el fin de semana No habíamos
previsto No pensábamos que Boris Johnson
quizá iba a entrar a la competición
claramente no ha tenido los avales
suficientes con lo cual hoy esta noche
hablamos de sunat como este gran Primer
Ministro este gran Salvador digamos del
partido conservador y de la situación
realmente de antesca que está viviendo
Gran Bretaña durante las últimas semanas
Durante los últimos meses Durante los
últimos años desde el brexit yo creo que
entre los principales desafíos que tiene
Rising sunak en Gran Bretaña como bien
ha comentado el en nuestro compañero es
de México de Amazon
por supuesto están Están todas las
cuestiones políticas pero también hay
una cuestión muy importante Por supuesto
el parece que ha sido elegido porque
tiene una gestión y un conocimiento de
las cuestiones económicas importantes
pero luego hay un problema importante
del legitimidad recordemos que él no se
no se ha presentado a ninguna
selecciones no ha ganado nada más allá
que dentro del partido conservador con
lo cual Esto va a ser dentro de la
rendición de cuentas va a ser un peso
importante sobre sus hombros y luego
también una cuestión territorial muy
importante en Gran Bretaña no está en
Londres contra el resto de Gran Bretaña
y parece que ahí también Boris Johnson
prometió de alguna manera que iba a
nivelar los diferentes lugares de Gran
Bretaña y Esto va a ser una asignatura
pendiente bastante pesada para el señor
Oscar continuó con usted para hacerla la
ronda la inversa en una entrevista que
Dios unac a la cadena bbc que es la
televisión pública británica en su
momento dijo que prefería perder la
carrera por el liderazgo de su partido y
no llegar al cargo de Primer Ministro
antes que ganar estas estas votaciones
con falsas promesas y dice que
prácticamente eso fue lo que llevó al
fracaso a ese corto gobierno de list
Trust esto lo hace ver como una persona
que es digamos mucho más transparente o
mucho más conocedor de la necesidad que
tiene el pueblo británico de sentir que
va por un camino seguro en un mundo de
incertidumbres porque no solamente el
Reino Unido va atravesando un escenario
de incertidumbre política y económica y
que tal vez tiene una política económica
mucho más aterrizada Qué pensamiento
puede uno hacer o análisis de esa
declaración que dio a la bbc Bueno desde
luego el señor sunat lo que vende es
honestidad lo que vende es algo
diferente al hombre blanco digamos que
ha gobernado a Gran Bretaña durante
mucho tiempo él él recordemos que va a
ser el Primer Ministro hindú un Primer
Ministro cuya familia no sé si habéis
visto un vídeo que circula en el que él
presentaba su candidatura en el que él
vende seriedad honestidad él se coloca
muy muy muy cerca del pueblo digamos
puesto que tiene una historia personal
muy muy vendible a un nivel de
comunicación política vamos a ver yo
creo que él en la primera ronda también
hubiera preferido haberle ganado a
listras incluso Si hubiera tenido que
trucar un poquito los números yo creo
que sinceramente que ahora
Él llega con un trampolín mucho más
importante que si hubiera ganado las
primarias al stroess yo creo que en el
principio no son buenas noticias para el
Reino Unido Este cambio tan radical y
sobre todo las expectativas que crea que
creas bueno con una candidatura de
unidad recordemos que hoy podríamos
estar hablando de una competición feroz
de una fatización de el partido
conservador y sin embargo estamos
hablando digamos de que llega El Mesías
de una unidad tremenda que recordemos
también que tampoco ha hecho
declaraciones a lo largo del día con lo
cual Supongo que está dejando dejando a
asuna que coja su su
protagonismo innecesario en estos en
estos días con lo cual vamos a ver yo
soy un poco escéptico de este este gran
esta gran plataforma que que se ha
montado ahora mismo Tendremos que ver
Cuándo empieza a trabajar Que supongo
que será ya mañana porque tiene una
labor ingente desde luego ya vamos a
analizar esos puntos de la agenda que
tiene el Primer Ministro es una para
hacer frente de los múltiples frentes
que tiene abiertos el Reino Unido
regreso con damas o en México para darle
sobre esta esta declaración esto que
respondía Óscar sobre lo que dijo en la
bbc de mostrarse como con un programa
mucho más prometedor mucho más
transparente mucho más aterrizado y citó
algo que dije yo al inicio del programa
Y es que el que ríe de último ríe mejor
definitivamente él se le
acomodó el escenario perfecto para
llegar al cargo de Primer Ministro pero
una cosa es lograr mantenerse que ya
listos demostró que llegar puede ser
fácil pero mantenerse allí no lo es
en efecto hay que recordar que en el
caso de listros ella llevó a cabo más
acciones de corte política como para dar
respuestas inmediatas me atrevería que
decir hasta populistas haciendo este
plan que finalmente fue su tumba ahora
precisamente rish
viniendo de la cartera de economía de de
finanzas de la secretaría o del
Ministerio de Hacienda evidentemente
tiene digamos esta experiencia que
también le otorgó la pandemia en su plan
económico que sí generó empleos pero
también generó algunas críticas
Precisamente en su falta de mayor ayuda
a los hogares Ahora sunat tiene esta
oportunidad de presentarse como un
político pues joven relativamente y como
una persona con ciertos conocimientos
digamos sobre esta materia
su discurso que dio apenas hace unas
horas comentó que tenía dos grandes
retos el primero era precisamente el
económico generar la estabilidad lo cual
es una tarea enorme se dice fácil pero
sin lugar a dudas es enorme tiene que
generar estas confianzas que no pudo
generar listos con un plan económico
confiable y que tenga digamos el apoyo
no Además del partido por supuesto
conservador de los mercados de los
empresarios de los inversionistas y al
mismo tiempo Que responda como ya se ha
apuntado a las clases trabajadoras a una
situación de inflación que no ha tenido
digamos paralelo en muchos años en el
Reino Unido y el banco de Inglaterra El
Banco Central anunció que entrarían a
una recesión casi Inevitable y todo esto
es lo que va a afectar a la gente de a
pie es ahí yo creo que sunat tiene
encontrar esta respuestas económicas
para dar por un lado confianza a los
mercados y por el otro lado también
respuestas claras al ciudadano de a pie
es un gran reto y el otro gran reto que
presentó también zonas es el de la
unidad la unidad del partido conservador
que sabemos que ahora mismo está
dividido pero también la unidad del
pueblo británico están viviendo momentos
muy complicados y esto evidentemente son
cosas que tendrá que tomar
sunatha damas o continuó con usted
viendo aquí estamos viendo solo un
fotograma de toda la escena Si vemos la
escena de lo que es el Reino Unido vemos
un país que está desde hace varios años
digámoslo así desde que comenzó el
proceso del brexit en una transición o
en un cambio a todo nivel se salen de la
Unión Europea se muere la Reina Isabel
hay un cambio en El Monarca hay cambios
en en los nombres de los primeros
ministros el país en una gran transición
a todo nivel es lo que necesita en este
momento el Reino Unido para completar
este proceso de transición una persona
joven que siempre se le ha criticado a
la política inglesa que siempre se apega
a esas viejas a esas viejas figuras
políticas o sea primeros ministros un
poco desentonados con la con la
actualidad y con la con lo que está
viviendo el mundo llega con nuevas ideas
proponiendo esta transición lo que dice
usted tratando de generar confianza y
tal vez marcándole un rumbo al Reino
Unido que así vaya hacia una recesión el
país tenga un Norte Hacia dónde se tiene
que dirigir esto completaría de pronto
ese proceso de cambio que está viviendo
el país a todo nivel
bueno es que esa es una situación
bastante compleja ya lo había comentado
nuestro camarada Óscar
es bueno que sea un político joven es
bueno que tenga en su persona estas
cualidades de una persona trabajadora
seria que cumple metas Eso es importante
pero sin lugar a dudas también tiene que
generar esta confianza en todo el pueblo
británico en todo el Reino Unido Porque
además como ya se había mencionado él no
proviene de una digamos selección
general que de ser el caso por supuesto
que tendría la confianza en su programa
político en su partido él proviene de
este cónclave del partido conservador y
es por eso que tiene entonces una doble
o triple tarea precisamente la de
generar esta legitimidad de su persona
como Primer Ministro y también lo que
llama la atención es una persona que que
es la primera minoría el Reino Unido
este que que llega al poder que también
es importante tomarlo en consideración
en este sentido sin lugar a duda
es una tendrá que trabajar doble
triplemente para poder lograr en una
situación que no debo decir que que las
tiene todas consigo Más bien yo diría
que no las tiene todas consigo y Mario
Yo diría que está posicionado en una
situación más adversa que más positiva
claro las piezas se acomodaron para que
él llegara a este punto pero el
escenario ya en este punto es es muy
complicado lo que tiene que llegar a
enfrentar el nuevo Primer Ministro
continuo con Óscar en la ciudad de
Madrid tocó justamente ese tema que
estaba poniendo damas o sobre la mesa y
es que es una representa un nuevo aire
político pero también representa a las
minorías en cierta forma y también es un
Primer Ministro que llega al poder pero
que no representa a las clases
trabajadoras no representa al británico
de a pie él viene de una clase social
más alta lo han señalado por eso porque
su esposa viene de una familia adinerada
de Estados Unidos y e incluso han dicho
que tiene una fortuna mayor que la del
mismo monarca Carlos III Entonces eso
también genera otro punto de análisis
sobre todo que venga de una familia de
inmigrantes
bueno como como suscribo plenamente el
análisis de damas o desde desde México
Vamos a ver los ingleses están
acostumbrados a gobernantes que no
vienen de las clases trabajadoras
digamos que esta dualidad de oxbridge no
de la Universidad de Oxford y de
Cambridge de la que salen todos los
todos los gobernantes y la mayoría de
los miembros del parlamento británico
Pues bueno es una democracia además que
está montada de una manera muy elitista
entonces a partir de ahí hay un límite
de cuánto el señor sunak va a poder
hacer una performance digamos de
inmigrante de segunda generación que
está más cerca del pueblo que conoce los
los problemas reales de la gente cuando
en realidad en lo que parece que tenemos
también es un problema importante de
cara dentro del partido no solo cara a
los votantes entonces parece que el
brexit que recordemos que ha sido la
razón principal por la que partido
conservador se ha roto por lo menos en
dos piezas muy importantes por un lado
estamos los euroescépticos digamos muy
extremos junto con los Ultra liberales y
luego dentro del partido conservador
vive un ala moderada como el señor sunat
que recordemos que el señor sunat es un
conservador que ha subido los impuestos
en Gran Bretaña es un conservador que es
digamos un conservador muy poco al gusto
de El ala dura de los conservadores en
Gran Bretaña con lo cual sí que yo creo
que esto no es necesariamente malo
porque los mercados ya han reaccionado
de una manera muy favorable a la llegada
de sunat y recordemos que en los
mercados fueron aquellos que hundieron a
alistras con lo cual Bueno pues vamos
vamos a ver qué cartas se saca de la
manga porque puede ser un regalo
envenenado de hecho acordaos Santiago
dámasos y nosotros ya hemos estado aquí
hace 40 personas analizando los retos de
litros posiblemente ninguno de nosotros
hubiera podido predecir que hubiera sido
la primera ministra más corta digamos
con un tiempo más corto en down Street
Entonces vamos a ver porque igual
Santiago nos tienes que volver a llamar
dentro de unas semanas porque el señor
sunac se ha encontrado dentro de un de
un de un jeroglífico que no puede
resolver no de un laberinto del que no
puede salir veremos a ver No desde aquí
por supuesto le deseamos suerte pero no
no va a ser fácil claro todos los
escenarios son posibles en este momento
todavía no sabemos cómo va a gobernar ni
Qué línea va a tomar ni qué decisiones
va a tomar en muchos Campos Óscar
continuó con usted en la ciudad de
Madrid justamente usted menciona bueno
Dámaso también lo traía a colación el
tema de las divisiones que hay dentro
del partido de los conservadores que él
no representa muchos de los valores tal
vez más tradicionales y por eso genera
un poco ahí de diferencias en algunos
puntos sobre todo en el económico esto
que tanto va a ser una piedra en el
zapato para él para gobernar esto que
tanto le va a impedir
esa facilidad o toma de decisiones
es bueno Por supuesto que vas a ser algo
muy complicado para él porque piensas
Santiago que en ese partido conservador
claro lo que no estamos hablando es por
qué Gran Bretaña tiene dos Solo dos
partidos no dos partidos relevantes y
esto se trata de un tipo de democracia
que está montada para una sociedad
relativamente homogénea y con dos
partidos que son moderadamente
moderadamente en torno a una ideología
que no nunca llega a ser extrema digamos
que que tanto Gran Bretaña como a
Estados Unidos
estos sistemas de dos partidos no
soportan bien y no y no conviven bien
con la polarización ideológica a partir
de ahí en cualquier país de Europa que
tuviéramos este mismo problema Por
supuesto esto Serían dos partidos que si
están en la misma colección romperían
con lo cual hay que ver también
procesos de cambio más estructural
dentro de la Democracia británica Porque
algunos de estos arreglos
institucionales ya no funcionan bien
este bipartidismo no refleja en absoluto
la la sociedad británica no refleja en
absoluto las diferentes
regiones o imaginamos con su propio
apartamento Escocia gales con su propio
parlamento el norte de Irlanda con su
propio parlamento Y estos parlamentos
realmente están capados de funciones
porque en Londres maneja todo el poder
absolutamente todo el poder entonces
deberíamos de mirar y el señor sunacaría
bien Mirando a unas reformas quizá un
poco más estructurales y un poco más
profundas dentro del sistema porque si
no vamos a posiblemente a repetir los
mismos errores en un futuro cercano
en México qué piensa usted sobre este
tema la unidad de los conservadores esto
que tanto va a facilitar o que tanto
pone en peligro o tener un gobierno de
sunac que sea un poco más prolongado de
los 45 días que tuvo que tuvo atrás
Sí bueno sin lugar a dudas hay que
recordar que digamos Esta división del
partido conservador inicia precisamente
con con lo que fue el brexit todo el
proceso del brexit que tuvimos también a
una Teresa médica cayó en fin ha sido
una relatoría de fracasos políticos de
los líderes conservadores de los
primeros ministros conservadores en todo
el proceso y ahora lo que tenemos es
esta anatomía en la cual
el propio Boris Johnson que de alguna
manera pensó que pudiera regresar Pero
obviamente un bloque importante el
partido conservador dijo si él regresa a
nosotros renunciamos ya ahí tenemos Esta
división y la otra candidata que es
Penny morton que en principio se decía
que que sí podía representar a varios
sectores del propio partido conservador
no la alcanzaron el número de los votos
entonces Bueno ahí también nos habla de
esta debilidad Y pareciera que que que
el tercero en discordia el que estaba
ahí parado es precisamente
que si bien no representa todos los
digamos colores del partido conservador
pues pareciera que era el candidato pues
más obvio y y pues no había digamos
mayores opciones no pero esto no quiere
decir que el personalice toda una gran
unidad por eso él habló en su discurso
de que una de las grandes tareas junto a
la tarea de la economía era la unidad
que trabajaba por la unidad del partido
y por supuesto también por la unidad
nacional como en este gran movimiento
nacional para salir adelante de esta
gran crisis política insisto y también
económica por la cual atraviesa el Reino
Unido en efecto hay una gran división
también hay una gran división al
interior del propio Reino Unido ya lo
había mencionado Óscar no esta idea de
Escocia que todavía está un poco ahí en
el aire de poderse obtener su soberanía
el problema con las irlandas de la
frontera dura o no a partir de la
pertenencia de Unión Europea
precisamente de una de ellas y todo esto
estaba marcando serias divisiones que
sin lugar a dudas este el señor
va a tener que ser muy habilidoso y muy
inteligente para poder un poco curar
esta situación dama me interesa ese tema
de la unidad del Reino Unido vemos Que
Escocia está empujando por poder
realizar otra vez un referendo para
buscar la independencia ellos no estaban
de acuerdo con la salida de la Unión
Europea y quieren que Escocia pertenezca
a la Unión Europea las divisiones y las
tensiones con los diferentes países que
componen el Reino Unido Son son latentes
están ahí presentes pero vemos que por
ejemplo el gobierno de Boris Johnson y
de listros pues no tuvo suficiente
tiempo como para poner algo en marcha
es poco lo que están haciendo para poder
empezar por lo menos a tener diálogo
entre Londres y edimburgo en Londres y
cardif Londres y belfast para mejorar
esas diferencia
esto es un tema
preocupante a largo plazo Dámaso que
esto se pueda empezar a profundizar
estas grietas estas divisiones y llegué
a un punto Irreversible donde el Reino
Unido simplemente se descomponga en
cuatro países independientes
no sé si Irreversible pero sí creo que
es una situación real que ahí existe y
aquí el punto es que las crisis
económicas recordemos siempre disparan
estas emociones políticas y estos
nacionalismos Sin lugar a dudas si esta
crisis económica golpea a los habitantes
de obviamente gales nueva Escocia
Irlanda pues puede un político
habilidoso tomar este parte de esta
situación y transformarla en un discurso
nacionalista que vaya precisamente a
estos movimientos de independencia estos
referéndum es un escenario muy difícil
es un escenario muy complicado y porque
sabemos que la antigua Reina Isabel II
pues tenía esta capacidad un poco de
poder unir bueno murió finalmente en
Escocia en su casa de descanso que
llamaba mucho y Pero esto ya se acabó es
una nueva era y mi único temor aquí es
que en este contexto de crisis económica
sumada a la crisis política puedan
avivarse estos sentimientos
nacionalistas y por supuesto en
Independencia claro Óscar Dámaso les
parece si escalamos esto un poco más
allá de el tema interno y de los
problemas dentro del Reino Unido y lo
escalamos al nivel Europa Europa también
está en una especie de
crisis de Liderazgo también está lo de
la guerra en Ucrania y está la atención
que hay entre Londres y Bruselas
justamente Aquí hay una oportunidad para
el Reino Unido para recuperar un poco de
posición de Liderazgo un poco de visi en
Europa después del brexit y también para
bajar un poco la atención con Bruselas
como lo vio usted Óscar
sin duda sin duda Santiago vamos a ver
en Europa somos muchos los que estamos
esperando que Gran Bretaña
vuelvan no vuelva a la Unión Europea que
esto sería un escenario para alguno de
nuestros ideal en el futuro cercano pero
que vuelva a la mesa de negociación
vuelva a la digamos a hablar de las
cuestiones europeas en y creo que puede
ser que sunat sí que sea un mejor
candidato que que Boris Johnson un mejor
candidato sin duda que Lis tras quizá
está menos tocado por la varita del
brexit la varita digamos mágica pero
dramáticamente mágica no entonces Bueno
sí que en Europa hay gente que por
supuesto está mirando esta crisis del
Reino Unido con una media sonrisa en la
boca no estamos hablando de una Europa
que también está sufriendo mucho de la
crisis económica pero en la que estamos
no estamos 27 27 países Unidos dentro de
esta calamidad que tenemos encima y
parece que lo que viene más adelante
pero también tenemos problemas
evidentemente pensemos en Italia con la
señora meloni pensemos en macron que
tiene frentes internos abiertos
importantes pensemos en Alemania Y en
este invierno del descontento que vamos
a vivir con el gas tendremos la Guerra
de Ucrania pero sin embargo sí que hay
una sensación Medal me da la impresión
en Europa de que de que la solidaridad
nos salva nos salva de alguna manera y
quisiéramos quisiéramos atraer de alguna
manera
al Reino Unido a que comparta con
nosotros algunos de estos problemas y
que por supuesto es lo que podamos
ayudarles Pues sería una cuestión
bastante importante vamos a ver qué
capacidad de diálogo muestra sunac con
Europa pensemos que como ha apuntado
Dámaso el tema de Irlanda del norte de
las dos irlandas el tema de la frontera
está muy viva recordemos también que hay
un repunte de violencia en Irlanda del
Norte recordemos también que es el
sinfín el partido que ha ganado las
últimas elecciones por por primera vez
en toda la historia de Irlanda del Norte
con lo cual vemos un escenario muy
complicado que quizás sea manejar de una
manera muy difícil solo no dentro de
Europa parece que las cosas se veían de
otra manera ahora es muy difícil para el
señor sunat además de arreglar
internamente no lo que pedíamos de las
diferentes regiones pero no solo las
diferentes regiones Liverpool Manchester
leads todas estas todas estas ciudades
que se ven de alguna manera
discriminadas y ninguneadas desde
Londres con lo cual Bueno vamos vamos a
ver yo yo yo yo soy optimista por
naturaleza y creo que este señor además
Bueno pues tiene muy buena imagen es
joven creo que que no tiene Esta esta
este marchamo de de old school
conservador y puede ser que sí que sea
más dialogante y sí que sea más
tolerante con las cuestiones que vengan
desde desde Europa Ojalá damas o cuál es
su opinión por el lado de Óscar hay
optimismo lo ve como que puede funcionar
Boris Johnson incluso era tuvo un papel
en cierta forma protagónico en la Guerra
de Ucrania estuvo en kiev para varias
veces y reiteró constantemente el apoyo
del Reino Unido a través de la otan a
Ucrania y a los países del Báltico aquí
puede haber una oportunidad para Sonic
ya veíamos entonces que Óscar es
positivo al respecto Cuál es su opinión
yo también soy positivo con ciertas
limitaciones Sin lugar a dudas una de
las tareas que va a tener este registro
en materia política exterior es
reconstruir su relación y su posición
precisamente frente a Europa en lo
general y la unión european lo
particular el compromiso del papel que
tiene el Reino Unido en la otan es
básico e importantísimo y más por su
relación natural transatlántica con los
Estados Unidos lo cual le da una
posición también privilegiada dije que
optimizar limitado porque sin lugar a
dudas para que sunat pueda ser un factor
y un actor importante y creíble pues
tiene que consolidar todas estas
políticas y poner orden en casa
recordemos muy rápidamente La estrategia
de negociación que tuvo Teresa May
cuando estaba viéndolo del brexit de
Llamar acá de llevar a cabo estas
elecciones pensando que estaría más
fortalecida y le salió muy mal el asunto
Y en lugar de salir más fortalecía salió
más debilitada lo hizo porque sabía que
necesitaba esta legitimidad dar a Europa
esta imagen de que tenía un gran
sustento Ese es el sustento precisamente
que son va a tener que trabajar y
obtenerlo para que se convierta en un
actor importante en una figura
importante Por supuesto que lo mejor que
le pudiera pasar a Europa es un Reino
Unido fuerte un Reino Unido convencido
porque aunque esté fuera digamos en esta
idea del brexit el Reino Unido es y
formará parte de Europa y de mucho en
sus políticas y eso Aliado natural más
frente a esta embestida rusa
Precisamente en Ucrania entonces tengo
confianza en que seguramente por el
perfil señor zona va a trabajar
duramente y esperemos de ese trabajo y
esa habilidad política que pudiera tener
le dieron buenos resultados Dámaso esa
legitimidad como gana esa legitimidad
eso se logra a través de acciones
rápidas debido a las múltiples crisis
que está viviendo el Reino Unido En
diferentes niveles o en tener una mano
dura para tomar decisiones como muchos
le reclamaron a listros y cuando puso
una mano dura Ya no les gustó lo que
estaba tratando de hacer a nivel
económico Cómo ganar esa legitimidad y
porque ahí vemos los dos casos
anteriores que justamente ser rápido o
ser efectivo o ser de mano dura les jugó
en contra
Sin lugar a dudas y hay que tenemos el
tiempo en contra precisamente de sunat
porque desafortunadamente va a tener que
hacer acciones rápidas No porque él
quisiera sino porque no le quedan muchas
opciones más que tomar acciones rápidas
con resultados rápidos pero que a
diferencia de litros sean más viables
sean más confiables no sean un elemento
que disruptivo de los mercados Entonces
yo creo que esto lo tiene claro el
propio señor sunac que sí va a tener y
va a tener que tomar rápidas con
resultados rápidos pero digamos de alta
confiabilidad tanto los mercados como en
el pueblo digamos de a pie bueno
llegamos al bloque final del programa
Óscar damas o quiero que hagamos las
conclusiones lo que puede venir para el
Reino Unido para las próximas semanas
siempre lo digo ya es frase de oro aquí
en el debate no tenemos la bola de
cristal para saber qué va a pasar pero
que auguran ustedes un buen desempeño al
frente del Reino Unido Cuál va a ser ese
frente primero atacar la economía la
parte social o la confianza al interior
del partido y de los británicos comienzo
por Óscar
bien pues yo sin duda soy yo sigo siendo
optimista vamos a ver Santiago Dámaso
llega el invierno llega el invierno en
Gran Bretaña con una crisis energética
importante la gente no sabe si va a
poder pagar la factura de la
electricidad la estructura del gas las
diferentes facturas no sabe la inflación
está desbocada como todos sabemos con lo
cual lo primero es que intentar que se
deje de hablar del gobierno y se empiece
a hablar de las soluciones que está
proponiendo el gobierno yo creo que esto
es fundamental que se deje de hablar del
número 10 de Down Street que se deje de
hablar de El que el Rey Carlos que se
dejen de hablar de las diferentes
conspiraciones y que se empiece a hablar
de política Yo creo que es una que es un
hombre es un político que controla muy
bien el relato y creo que a partir de
mañana tiene que empezar a hablar de las
historias de la gente no de su propia
historia sino de las historias de sacar
a la gente y además no solo a los
continentes solo a la clase a la clase
digamos más acomodadas sino a la clase
política a la clase social que necesita
en estos momentos un apoyo más
importante y recordemos que hay niveles
de pobreza y de desigualdad muy
superiores a las que encontramos en el
Continente con lo cual creo que esto es
importante
con Óscar Yo creo que es sunac va a
tener que dar resultados muy inmediatos
sabemos que en las próximas horas va a
tener un conclave con el partido
precisamente conservador para presentar
las líneas generales de su gobierno en
materia económica y creo que el partido
conservador va a tener que dar a este
espaldarazo este apoyo total
precisamente para dar confianza a este
plan que seguramente va a ser más serio
que el que presentó nuestros que
respondía más a cuestiones políticas y
en ese sentido este pudiera ser un buen
comienzo Pues a Óscar y además soy y
también a los televidentes esta historia
apenas está comenzando vamos a ver cómo
se este nuevo gobierno de Sonia allí en
el Reino Unido les agradezco mucho por
haber hecho este análisis o para la
audiencia de France 24 gracias por haber
estado con nosotros es todo por hoy En
nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos la sintonía de la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y la producción de invitados a
cargo de Tania Herrera ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]